asking a question or pseudo how much
psychology can you put into a manga if I
were to ask this question to a Toyota
the author of one piece his answer would
probably be everything or at least
something along that line in fact I
would argue that the psychology behind
Oda's characters is the single biggest
reason that his story appeals to such a
broad audience up to this day and I mean
that quite literally regardless of way
of from or how old you are you can enjoy
the story as a teenager looking at it
through innocent and excited eyes
enjoying the fights cheering for the
characters and feeling the impact of the
major emotional moments of the show
however a lot of the major characters in
the story also have their subtleties
that aren't immediately noticeable
without a certain amount of personal
life experience such nuances have been
constructed in such a way that they add
a subtle but impactful portion of
realism and depth that make them more
and more relatable throughout the years
these characters especially reflect
parts of the human mind and persona that
might be picked up upon only by someone
who has had a similar experience or have
had enough life experience to
consciously or maybe even unconsciously
pick up on these subtle underlying
themes of some of these characters in
other words psychology is intertwined
all throughout one piece and can be
found distinctly for each character
today however I want to explore with you
the thematic mind of one person in
particular to examine what impact his
theme has on the audience and to
demonstrate how psychology can cleverly
be made visible in a medium like manga
and anime so let's talk about the purple
tiger let's talk about marine admiral
fujitora his blind justice and why it
makes him the best develop admiral
of the laws fujitora or as he's actually
called a show is a broadly billed
middle-aged man that has been recruited
into the ranks of the Marines after the
time-skip
his most prominent features are the deep
scars over his eyes that marked the
spots where ishow blinded himself with
his sword after having witnessed
something truly horrific his character
design is dominated by his samurai like
appearance that have made it easy to
speculate that he has some connection to
wanna say mess the other Admirals Fujii
Torres character has been based on a
Japanese actor in Fujii Torres case that
is Shintaro katsu or
more specifically his role as Sato Ichi
the blind swordsman both characters
share a number of distinct similarities
for instance both Korea Chico mizuha a
cane sword that they use for both
walking and fighting both share a love
for gambling a theme that is especially
pronounced with a show who not only
likes to gamble literally but he also
likes to roll the dice when it comes to
fights and important decisions he
literally does so when torn between duty
and morale having to decide whether or
not to assist a flamingo against the
straw hats we can also see this in his
standoff with law endo flamingo when he
brings down a meteor without certainty
who or what it would hit in the ends
they both try to help the people out of
the misery as best as they can and in
that sense both of them are also
extremely humble not taking a lot of
pride in themselves especially compared
to some of his colleagues fujitora
certainly does not see himself as
superior or as a force of authority to
others notably well he has enjoyed more
screen time than most of the other
admirals in the story there is not much
that we know about he shows past we do
know that he was born somewhere on the
Grand Line possibly guano and that at
some point in his life he decided to
blind himself after being overwhelmed by
the
of the world a possibility in that
regard is that this event had something
to do with wha No
and maybe the horrific execution of Odin
by Orochi and Kaito should he actually
be from wha no that would certainly have
been enough reasons to explain his
painful past however whatever the
trigger for this tragic decision might
have been we can be sure that fujitora
has suffered through a lot in his life
it is a pain literally made visible to
the audience through the scars on his
face they serve as a constant reminder
of his suffering and hardship and the
trauma it must have left in his heart
despite being a Marine admiral and in
that sense an antagonist to luffy and a
straw hats it becomes clear very fast
that ishow is not meant to be an enemy
to the crew right from his introduction
Oda makes it clear that here we're
dealing with a very kind and emotional
man who does not realize he's even being
cheated on by the flamingo's man during
the gambling his kind heart and the
respect that he shows towards our
protagonists makes it very easy for us
as the audience to empathize with him
when he stops sorrow from attacking
doflamingo he literally apologizes for
his behavior after having been helped by
the crew early in the casino and in
general every major confrontation that
fujitora has over the course of the
dressrosa arc involves some sort of
moral and emotional dialogue with his
opponents no matter if it's sharing his
concerns over dressrosa with Sabo
stopping doflamingo from killing law or
even his short clash with Luffy at no
point do we perceive him as a true
threats much rather we see him as
someone with good intentions who is
opposing Luffy & Co based on his
responsibilities as a Marine all this
however does not mean in the slightest
that
ishow is not intimidating just the
opposite Oda makes it painfully clear
just how powerful the Marine is his
skills as a swordsman as well as his
powerful gravity devil fruit make it
very obvious why fujitora holds the rank
of a Marine
despite having been drafted into the
Marines merely two years ago but as we
all know power alone only seldomly makes
for a fascinating character and fujitora
in particular is a wonderful example of
how real human psychology can be
incorporated into a fictional character
in a way that creates a distinct and
relatable emotional response in an
audience in order to be able to dissect
and understand the true power of issues
personality from a storytelling
perspective we have to start with his
wound
however counter-intuitively to the
general perception of Shonen manga we're
actually not talking about the scars on
his face or any other physical wound
fujitora has suffered over the course of
his life much rather these scars serve
as a visual representation of a much
deeper psychological wound he has been
dealt this wound has its origin in
unseen horrible events the samurai had
to suffer through in the past and no
matter what it was that he had to
witness it must have been so terrible
that
Ischl felt no other way to deal with
this pain other than to mutilate himself
to escape from the cruelty of the world
grounded in this emotional wound is the
fundamental weakness that oda has chosen
for his intricate character the weakness
of a character can be defined as a lie
about the world a perceived false truth
if you will that they wrongfully believe
in and thus have to learn to overcome
for fujitora this weakness seems to be
the belief that piracy is an evil that
has to be destroyed in order to bring
lasting peace to the world what this
suggests to us is that his past
experiences most likely involved the
deeds of pirates in one way or another
this weakness subsequently reveals to us
the psychological need of the character
that determines his future character
development in other words the need is
the solution to the characters weakness
that he has to acquire through his own
actions and in Fujii Torres case this
clearly is the need to create a more
nuanced worldview
letting go of his hatred for pirates in
general however to turn the journey
towards this answer into a threat of
story that yields true moral insights
and experiences for both the character
and the read are like the psychological
need is usually unknown to the character
itself thus at the beginning of the
dressrosa arc each show appears to have
a very clear image of what is good and
what is bad in this worlds to mask his
emotional wound and avoid dealing with
it he hides it behind a mask and we can
see this very clearly in all of the
fights and confrontations that he has
where he lets go of his kind and gentle
nature and takes on a much harder and
more determined stance as a result we
the audience struggle with him as he
struggles between the ideals of the
world government the revolutionaries
doflamingo and the straw hats his desire
after all is to save and protect the
people of dressrosa
and in that sense the entire dressrosa
arc serves as an overarching
representation of what determines good
and evil and fujitora who has to figure
out who stands for what on this island
serves as a sort of personification of
the struggle so as a result this makes
the dressrosa story arc his central
character development arc as well and to
put it into the broader context of the
other admirals the change he undergoes
is basically from a chi know - Alki g'
roughly speaking at least to explain
this analogy let's take one step back
however
the first step in a show's character
development happens before we ever get
to meet him joining the Marines to fight
the evil that has caused him so much
pain already is a major step for him it
suggests that despite literally blinding
himself to not see any more of it he at
some point has decided to still face all
that evil again how he reached at
resolve and determination we do not know
yet however it also shows us that
fujitora believed the Marines to be a
force of good standing off against the
Pirates
thus Fujii Torres worldview at the
beginning of the arc comes very close to
what we know of a kind knew
ideologically at least however this
black-and-white view is very quickly
challenged by the actions taking by the
straw hats and doflamingo who is
affiliated with the world governments as
the events progressed we can see a show
struggle more and more with his belief
until he finally lets Luffy go
he finally lets go of his mask by
admitting to himself that Luffy is
actually a kind person when we reach the
end of the arc we have reached an
approach that comes much closer to our
ki G where fujitora enacts based on his
morality rather than his duty he learns
to judge people based on their actions
rather than their flag
thus he allows Luffy to escape while
taking it on himself to abolish the
system of the Warlord's that has caused
so much suffering in the world secretive
to know what then is Fujii Torres ideal
of blind justice to unearth that
question we once again have to return to
the fundamental theme of the Admirals is
everything we call evil actually evil
every one of the Admirals has their own
answer to this question and for fujitora
I would argue that his sense of justice
is very closely connected to his
character that we've just discussed the
first thought when thinking about blind
justice at least for me is the image of
Lady Justice
often depicted as wearing a blindfold
she represents impartiality in other
words the ideal that justice should be
applied without regard to wealth power
or any other status this description
hits really close to home when we think
about issues action and ideals this of
course is further supported by the fact
that fujitora is literally blind he
physically cannot discriminate against
people based on their appearance as we
can witness over the course of the story
fujitora decides to serve justice
according to people's deeds and not
their affiliation thus he increasingly
gets into conflict with the world
government's ideal of absolute justice
to give you a better idea of his
approach to justice let's look at two
impactful moments for his character the
first takes place after his standoff
with doflamingo and law after law is
taken out by the warlord fujitora steps
in to prevent Oh Flamingo from taking
lost life the fair and moral thing to do
here is to catch a law not execute him
and his job as an admiral is to serve
the justice he deserves not any more or
less he thus protects law from unjust
treatment by the Flamingo the second
instance is his confrontation with
sorrow being aware of the kindness that
the straw hats have showed towards him
he apologizes for standing in his way
and openly verbalizes his internal
struggle that is building up at this
point what this shows to us is that
fujitora is willing to take
responsibility for his actions even if
it means going against a canoe and the
goro say for letting luffy go and bowing
to King Riku and thus exposing the world
government's failure in this case it's
the just thing to do and fujitora serves
it just as Lady Justice woods
blindfolded thus he shows character
truly is psychology made visible his
scars literally represent his ideal of
blind justice if you enjoy
this video consider leaving me a like
and some of your thoughts in the
comments below also if you aren't
subscribed to the channel yet I hope I
could convince you that it might be
worth doing so welcome on boards I hope
to see around next time stay curious and
until then have a wonderful week